Bob is riding his bicycle along the same
path for 0 is less than or equal to T is
less than or equal to 10
Bob's velocity is modeled by B of T is
equal to T to the third minus 6t squared
+ 300 where T is measured in minutes and
B of T is measured in meters per minute
find Bob's acceleration at time T equals
5
well acceleration this is a velocity
function right over here so the
acceleration is going to be the
derivative of the velocity function with
respect to time huh what is the rate of
change of velocity with respect to time
that's acceleration so we really just
want to evaluate we this Bob's
acceleration at Bob's acceleration at T
equals 5 that's going to be V prime of 5
so let's first figure out what V prime
of T is V prime of T is equal to we'll
take the derivative here it's pretty
straightforward just use the power rule
so it's going to be 3t squared minus 12t
2 times negative 6 is 12 or negative 12
and then the derivative of 300 300
doesn't change with respect to time so
it's just zero and so V prime of 5 is
going to be equal to 3 times 5 squared
minus 12 times 5 which is equal to 75
minus 60 which is equal to 15 and the
unit's here this is acceleration so this
is going to be his velocity was in
meters per minute and so this is going
to be meters per minute per minute
because remember time is in terms of
minutes so we could write as meters we
write it out meters per minute per
minute which is the same thing as meters
per minute meters per minute squared I
let's do the next part based on the
model based on the model B from Part C
find Bob's average velocity during the
interval from zero is less than or equal
to T is less than or equal to 10 and if
the notion of average velocity or
average value of a function is
completely foreign to you I encourage
you to watch the videos on Khan Academy
on find the average of a function but
straight the just to kind of cut to the
chase the average velocity
the average velocity is going to be the
area under the velocity curve divided by
our change in time so the area under the
velocity curve from T equals zero to T
equals 10 of B of T of B of T DT divided
by our change in time so it's going to
be divided by well the going from zero
to 10 so 10 minus zero is going to be
equal to 10 and if you wanted the
intuition here it's like well if you
know the area of something and if you
wanted to find its average height you
could just divide by its width and
that's what we're doing here if we know
the area of something we want to figure
out its average height and so you divide
by its width that's I guess a very high
level intuition for where this where
this expression came from and so this is
going to be equal to one tenth times the
integral from zero to ten and B of T is
T to the third power minus six T squared
plus 300 DT and so this is going to be
equal to one over ten take the
antiderivative here so this is going to
be T to the fourth over four T to the
fourth over four and then this is going
to be if we increase the exponent here
by one is T to the third and then you
divide by three so it's negative six
divided by three is negative two T to
the third and then plus 300 T 300 T and
I'm going to evaluate it I am going to
evaluate it at 10 and subtract from that
it evaluated at zero and so this is
going to be equal to it is going to be
equal to one tenth that same one tenth
there when you evaluate all of this at
10 what are we going to get let's see 10
to the fourth power is 10 to the fourth
power is 10,000 divided by four is 2500
2500 and then minus 2 times 10 to the
third so it's 2 times a thousand so
minus 2
thousand and then 300 times ten
well that's plus three thousand and then
you subtract all of this evaluated at
zero which is just going to be zero
so this is going to be equal to 2500 -
2000 is 500 plus 3000 this is all
simplifies to 3500 or 3500 and then you
divide it by ten this is going to be 350
350 and it's an average velocity meters
per 350 meters per minute and we are
done